[Musique]
grâce à cette exposition vous ne
regarderez plus votre verre de bière de
la même façon ou plutôt vous le
regarderai
[Musique]
parce que ce que montre la maison des
arts de la table cette année c'est
justement à quel point le monde des
verts est vaste à cette exposition vous
présente à peu près plus de 3000 vert
vert shop boc on a 26 nations qui sont
représentés donc ils sont tous
différents et si on s'accroche sur
chacun de ces verres uni place un grand
moment un grand moment de plaisir
parmi ces objets il y a ceux qui
racontent l'histoire comme c'est drôle
de verdi cocher ou quoi qu il aurait été
inventé par un brasseur belge pour les
cochers qui pouvait ainsi voir sans
quitter leur attelage enfin il paraît il
y aussi une autre version au niveau du
couac c'est parce que paraît-il moi j'ai
jamais essayé mais quand on boit le vert
un peu cul sec à la fin du verre ça fait
un petit bruit qui fait crac autre
rareté à découvrir ses verres et carafes
qui ressemblent à des oeuvres d'art
ce sont pourtant bien des services à
bière créé par un maître verrier vosgien
dans le sillage de l'art nouveau